[Musique]
le climat la biodiversité le cycle
végétal autant de notions sur
l'environnement que les élèves de
l'école primaire
Ernest Velia du tampon ont pu acquérir
grâce au travail pédagogique mené par la
splden dans le cadre de l'opération la
forêt s'invite à l'école une opération
qui a permis à la SPL d'être récemment
distingué par un prix le trophée des
Outre-mer qui récompensent les projets
les plus remarquables mobilisateurs
pédagogique et exemplaires ce mercredi
19 avril à l'issue de la commission
permanente les élus du département ont
donc tenu à saluer cette distinction en
recevant les acteurs de ce beau projet
dans l'hémicycle du Palais de la source
je tiens salué à remercier la présidence
le directeur et de l'ensemble des
services de la super Eden pour tout le
travail qui effectué qui est reconnu
l'année dernière la SPLA a été primé sur
le plan national et cette année
en lien avec l'école Velia du tampon et
bien l'action Speller à nouveau reconnu
à la réunion nous avons un savoir-faire
nous avons une exemplarité en matière de
transition écologique c'est quoi cela
que j'ai je suis heureux de voir que
l'école il y a du temps pour a été
récompensé nous avons remis des diplômes
à chaque moment en ayant une pensée pour
les écoliers qui ont participé à cette
opération et l'ensemble du corps
enseignant à travers cette opération la
SPL Eden a proposé plusieurs animations
pédagogiques en lien avec l'école avec
notamment la visite du domaine
Archambault un espace naturel sensible
exceptionnel du département
de remettre plus de biodiversité dans
les écoles profiter de la ressource
génétique qui a dans nos forêts on avait
un projet d'arborétum dans une école
primaire
du coup on a tissé le lien vraiment
entre l'école et de mon Archambault et
via cet arboretum là dans l'école donc
la forêt s'invite à l'école on s'est dit
bah pourquoi pas travailler sur ce
projet là avec les enfants pour voilà et
postuler donc pour ce profil et on est
on a été primé et donc l'idée c'était de
renaturer remettre de la biodiversité
dans ses écoles là grâce au four et qui
sont à proximité la plantation de cet
arboretum d'espèces endémiques au sein
même de l'école rendu possible grâce à
la dotation biodiversité de la
collectivité départementale représente
le fruit d'un vrai travail collaboratif
entre la SPL le corps enseignant et les
marmailles donc le projet est né d'une
enseignante qui a voulu collaborer avec
le domaine Archambault qui est un espace
naturel sensible juste à côté de l'école
et de ce projet de classe est né un
projet d'école naturellement et voilà on
l'a mis au profit de l'école tout
entière donc les CP jusqu'au CM2 sont
allés au domaine Archambault pour une
visite et ensuite la splden est venu
plant avec les maternelles et ils ont
été encadrés par des CM1 CM2 voilà donc
aujourd'hui on a un arboretum de 40
plans environ qu'on essaie de continuer
à faire à vivre les maternelles s'en
occupent tous les jours sensibles aux
enjeux liés à la préservation des forêts
et de la biodiversité le président Cyril
Melchior a profité de cette occasion
pour mettre un coup d'accélérateur au
plan 1 million d'arbres de la
collectivité ce sont donc 50000 arbres
indigènes qui seront plantés cette année
dans les espaces naturels sensibles du
département avec l'appui de la SPL Eden
[Musique]